يرفع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مرة
أخرى شبح
الأسلحة النووية ، ويقول بوتين إن روسيا يمكن أن تستخدمها
للرد على التهديدات ، دعونا نجلب جيل دوهرتي ،
المساهم في شبكة CNN ورئيس مكتب موسكو السابق ،
إنها
أستاذة مساعدة في جامعة جورج تاون أه
جيل جيد أن تكونوا
كذلك.  نشر هذه
الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية في بيلاروسيا
وزير بيلكن يقول إن الولايات المتحدة
لا ترى أي دليل أو أي مؤشر على أن
الروس يعتزمون استخدامها ، فما
هي الرسالة التي يحاول بوتين إرسالها
بمجرد نقلها إلى بيلاروسيا
بشكل جيد وهو يفعل هذه الخطوة  تدريجيًا
تذكروا في شهر آذار (مارس) الماضي أنهم بدأوا في
الحديث عن هذا ، سنضع
أسلحة نووية تكتيكية في بيلاروسيا ، ثم
قالوا ، لكن علينا أن نبني
لهم الملاجئ والمباني الخاصة بهم ،
ثم استغرق ذلك شهرًا آخر ، لذلك هذا ما
تعلمونه.  الرسائل ببطء
بالطبع أن الغرب وحلف شمال الأطلسي
وأوكرانيا يجب أن يكونا خائفين للغاية من أن
روسيا ستستخدم الأسلحة النووية ، وهو
تكتيك تعرف أنه أقل فاعلية وأقل
فاعلية على ما أعتقد لأن التقييم
من قبل الولايات المتحدة هو حقًا أن
بوتين لا يريد  لبدء
حرب نووية تقول إنه لا يمكنك التخلص من
احتمال استخدامهم
أسلحة نووية تكتيكية ، لذا فأنت تعلم أن النظر إلى
خطاب الرئيس بوتين هذا كان في
الواقع خطابًا ثم نوعًا ما
مع شخص محلل يجب عليك فعلاً
فكر في تفسيره بالطريقة التي يجب أن
يفسر بها ،
وهو في رأيي نوعًا ما مثل مسبب الحريق العمد الذي
تعرفه مصابًا بهوس الحرائق الذي أشعل
حريقًا ثم يطفئ حريقه بنفسه ، لذا
فهو يرفع الرهان قائلاً حسنًا ، أنت تعلم أنه
يمكننا استخدام الطاقة النووية  أسلحة كبيرة
إذا لزم الأمر لحماية روسيا
ولكن ليست هناك حاجة لذلك هذا كل ما
تعرفه هو لا يقول أي شيء لمجرد
التسلية وأعتقد أن هذه
بالتأكيد رسالته لتخويف أه
الغرب ويجب أن نتذكر كل
هذا  هل نيرانه صحيحة ، هذه الحرب هي
نيرانه التي بدأها آه مرة أخرى في
فبراير من العام الماضي ، لذا دعني أسألك
عن إحضار القليل من
تقارير فريد التي نرى أن
الأوكرانيين يدعون بعض التقدم في
هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي كان  لقد
تحدثنا منذ عدة أشهر حتى الآن ، لكن لم
يربك الروس بوتين
يقول إنه ليس لديه فرصة هو أنه على
الإطلاق جزء من محادثة الأسلحة النووية هذه
حتى بما في ذلك السياق الذي
أضفته حول نوع أه
توقع هذه التحركات على مدى
الأشهر العديدة الماضية.
أعتقد أنك محق في أنهما على
الأرجح طريقتان يستخدمه
هذا الرقم الأول لم يفوز بهما نحن
أو على الأقل أنت تعلم أننا روسيا هو
يدعي أه يوقف
الأوكرانيين ومن ثم من
المنظور النووي يقول  لدينا هذه
الأسلحة ولكننا لسنا بحاجة لاستخدامها حقًا
لأنك تعلم أننا لا
نخسر الحرب لذا أعتقد مرة أخرى أنه
يستخدمها لعدة
أسباب مختلفة ولا تنسَ أن بعضًا من
هذا  يتحدث إلى شعبه
أم تعلم أن عبارة واحدة استخدمها في
ذلك q a مع أه مع الخبير كانت
تعبيرًا روسيًا غير ملون جدًا
وذكرني بالعودة إلى
حرب الشيشان أنه استخدم
وصفًا فاحشًا جدًا لما  كان سيفعل
مع الإرهابيين الذين كانوا يتمتعون بشعبية كبيرة في
بداية عهد بوتين ، لذلك عندما
يستخدم عبارات الرجل القاسي هذه عبارات صعبة نوعًا ما ،
فإنه دائمًا ما يرسل
رسالة إلى شعبه مفادها أنني لن أتعرض
للضغط.  أنا
مسيطر ولا تنسى أن الحرب لا
تسير بالطريقة التي توقعها وهناك
المزيد من الانتقادات حول كيفية
إدارته للحرب محليًا كما
قال بوتين أيضًا عن دبابات النمر وجميع
الأسلحة التي تأتي
لدعمها.  أوكرانيا أه بشكل عام وبالطبع
خلال هذا الهجوم المضاد قال إذا
كانوا متمركزين في الخارج لكنهم استخدموا في
القتال سنرى كيف نضربهم وأين
يمكننا ضرب تلك الوسائل التي
تستخدم ضدنا في القتال أشرت إلى
أن بوتين يفعل  لا يريد
حربًا نووية ، فهو أيضًا لا يريد حربًا مع الناتو ،
هل هذا هو المزيد من الضجيج ، هل هناك أي
سيناريو يمكنك من خلاله تخيل
إصابة القوات الروسية
بأصول موجودة في بولندا في ألمانيا في
دول أخرى مخصصة
لأوكرانيا ،
وكان هذا بالنسبة لي  الشيء الأكثر إثارة للقلق
الذي قاله إن الأسلحة النووية خطيرة ولكن
هذا في الحقيقة لأن ما كان
يقوله أعتقد أنه يمكن ذلك ونظرت إلى
ما قاله باللغة الروسية أنه يمكن تطبيقه
على الدبابات أو يمكن تطبيقه على طائرات f-16
وغيرها من الطائرات المقاتلة التي  ستذهب
إلى أوكرانيا أو ستذهب إلى أوكرانيا ، لذا
إذا كان يقول على سبيل المثال أن هناك
طائرات مقاتلة في بولندا أو في بحر البلطيق
أو في مكان ما في إحدى دول الناتو ، وهو
يقول إنه قد يكون كذلك ، ولم يكن
واضحًا للغاية ، فقد قال إننا سنرى ما نحن  سيفعل
ولكن هذا تهديد بأنه
سيهاجم دولة من دول الناتو لتدمير تلك
الطائرات وهو أمر خطير للغاية لأن ذلك
يبدأ حربًا ، لذا مرة أخرى يضغط على
الظرف وهو يلمح إلى أنه ليس
دقيقًا فيما يقوله ولكنه
تكتيك تخويف آخر  لن أجرب هذا
وإلا استطعت القدوم واستخدم
العبارة التي يمكن أن تحترق طائرات إف -16 تمامًا مثل
الدبابات